[Music]
the consequences of defunding the police
are leading to anarchy in america
cops are under attack while crime surges
all across the country
after portland was battered with a year
of riots an entire squad is now
resigning
the police department's 50-person crowd
control unit
is stepping down after one officer was
indicted for using excessive force
during the unrest last year and look at
this insane crime surge in portland
shootings are up 126 percent and
homicides have increased 530 percent
that's a lot other major cities like new
york and chicago are seeing a dramatic
increase in violence thanks to liberal
policies
and criminals are more brazen than ever
the nypd just put out a video of a man
getting
gunned down in broad daylight after
running into two
young children on the sidewalk
thankfully the kids were unharmed and
the victim is expected to survive
democrats are turning on their own like
this politician in the windy city
the problem is that you know the
democratic party on so many levels seems
to be
enamored with the mentality of being
enablers to criminality
and i am proof that you don't have to
cozy up the criminals to get reelected
you don't have to play identity politics
sometimes voters just want
truth all right let's just get this out
of the way greg where can people get the
t-shirt
you can get it at the fox uh store box
shop
yeah the fox shop i don't think they
have them in yet but i just got the
first one so i thought i would wear it
okay uh yes and it's got the exclamation
point
right we're talking about crime that is
a fashion crime thank you
and uh but jessica probably won't do
anything about it
i'm enjoying it actually but tell me
what you think about this
this guy from the windy city that's
chicago for those of you guys who don't
know that
he's saying that democrats think they
need to cuddle up to criminals to win
elections
i think there are two things going on
here number one
democrats don't like to be seen taking
the side
of of the opposition even if the
opposition is right
and i would say sometimes republicans
are like that as well but in this case
there's such overwhelming evidence that
people are dying because of your ego and
because you don't want to
you don't want to align yourself with
somebody you think is a moral or evil
republican
i just want to come up can we come up
with one city
in which there's a republican mayor and
there's trouble because i i spent
all night working at the library you
know the fox library
i couldn't find one example of a
republican mayor leading a city
that's that's in trouble the other point
is the biggest threat according to
president biden is the white supremacist
movement yet we don't we still don't
have the stats for that we don't have
the names
we don't have the organized crime gangs
that are causing crime sprees
in the name of white supremacy and yet
we know the names of the clowns
in oregon it's called antifa and they
tell us where they are
portland and yet that's called an idea
uh
when it's actually a really it's a
violent mob that is destroying a city
so basically what we're doing is we're
giving bad actors what they want by
denying they exist while chasing this
phantom
of white supremacy under every bed uh
and this is a replica like i said
yesterday of every bloody revolution you
start with uh
you know the ma when the population
gives in
to a to an immovable minority meaning a
small number of people
how many do we know how many people are
in antifa we don't do we just an idea
greg it's just an idea but it's a i bet
you could fit them in an auditorium
you probably could because they go from
city to city and i don't know if they've
been infiltrated by the fbi
to look into traveling carnival and now
this
50-person unit in portland has resigned
and mass
do you think something like that is
what's needed for
politicians to snap out of their days i
think it goes to show
how there's this widespread blanket
demoralization
uh with law enforcement in portland they
feel completely unprotected
uh they feel attacked by the the
the very vocal minority in the city
and the d.a there mike schmidt he is
awful i talked to my brother i've talked
about my brother a lot he was a cop in
gresham which is just outside portland
he was a parole probation officer for
years in multnomah county
and uh he is a shooting instructor
at the oregon state police academy so he
talks to cops all the time and he said
that proactive policing will go on the
decline this year they're going to be
cops are going to be like firefighters
they will only respond when something
bad happens
instead of going out talking to people
engaging
uh stopping stuff before it starts
because for them it's not worth it to
get indicted
and it just goes to show this sort of
revolt
they're standing up to a mayor a nutless
mayor
and a d.a who does not have their back
they will not
indict aggressive criminal felons who
are making
the city uh very unfree did you say
nutless i did he's
he's allergic he's allergic to an
allergy i think he'll feed ourselves
that's right very problematic and and
now children as we showed you before
deagan are getting caught in the
crossfire i mean thank god they're okay
but a stray bullet
goodbye your life's over and the parents
have to pick up the pieces
uh and did pro crime anti-cop and
law-abiding residents and victims just
have to fend for themselves
that that is the land of left-wing
lunacy and it starts with the governor
and you look here in new york
this is cuomo down to the mayor
de blasio the city council the district
attorneys
who have demonized not only demonized
police which has the same effect as
defunding the police
because it makes them step back and then
people retire
but also this has been going on for
years
that laws and changes to the books
that have let people free onto the
street
uh a couple of things i've talked to
cops all the time in the street and i i
always
i ask them how am i supposed to defend
myself strict gun laws here
you know what am i supposed to do i'm
like because if i
defend myself i'm going to be the one
who winds up in jail
they're going to throw me away and the
victim
will be on you know on msnbc and cnn
and that one friend of mine said i'd
rather be judged by 12 than carried by
six
i'd rather face a jury than wind up in a
coffin
in essence i think that one of the tests
will be this
uh the democratic primary for mayor here
in new york city
because there's one guy in the lead uh
adam's
former cop if he wins this primary he
will be the next mayor because
the other two are a disaster and i think
that if he wins this primary
like um there's catherine garcia who
wants police officers
um fine for not wearing masks last year
and then
maya wiley ran an ad demonizing the
nypd in a campaign and then she
literally vowed to slash the nypd's
budget because
trauma from dealing with cops is a
bigger problem than crime here
if if adams wins it will be a signal to
the rest of the democrats the lunatics
across the country
that that this anti-cop
pro-crime stance won't work anymore
jessica i opened up the new york post
today best paper in the country
only paper i read besides the wall
street journal also a great paper
and they had one of those little pie
charts which i love it's probably the
only chart i can understand i love pie
and the chart
and over 30 percent of democrat primary
voters say
crime is the number one issue they're
going to vote
on in this primary and this is something
that we have talked about for a whole
year democrats in the media have denied
that crime is even on the rise
it's an issue yet their own voters it's
their top priority by a mile
a hundred percent by a mile and daggan's
absolutely absolutely correct about eric
adams's rise to the top of the heap he
was running kind of in third or fourth
place andrew yang
was on top actually and eric adams
started talking about his policing
background and how we have to strike a
balance between
supporting those who wear the uniform
and ensuring that we have a fair and
equitable system and
get good criminal justice reform make
sure that you know people don't end up
in jail for the rest of their lives for
smoking and joint
now i assume he i think he is going to
win and this we're
her first time with rank choice voting
but what eric adams is talking about is
exactly what that alderman from chicago
is talking about and
it relates to greg's point which i think
is very well taken that it's incredibly
hard
for partisans especially in elected
office when the fringes are so
loud in terms of the supporters to say
you know what my colleague across the
aisle has a point about this
and that does cut both ways
unfortunately on this issue people end
up
dead because of it and i'm wondering
where the national discussion is
about reforms that we can have in these
major cities because do you remember
the group the of mayors the mayor's
alliance has started under mike
bloomberg
right where mayors from every major city
came together to say what is going to
work
for all of us and republican mayors came
and democratic mayors came and police
chiefs
and we need to hear more about that
because a lot of these problems are the
same
the same systemic issues in these cities
and i think that that would be a great
solutions oriented way forward biden
could
call on that for that to be happening
more publicly
i can tell you where i came from you
can't punch an old lady in the face and
break her nose and not go to jail and
get a desk appearance
ticket and that's exactly what happens
over and over again felony assault
right over and over again in new york
city and it basically you have to kill
somebody
to get thrown in jail around here and
that is a bail reform that was
shepherded
by the democrats can i just add
something to that very quickly
um if if you want real criminal justice
reform you got to stop talking to
republicans and democrats you have to
talk to libertarians
because they have been uh the most
critical and the most
reasonable about the issue for so long
and they're not having these
swinging emotional reactions to things
and they actually have
a really solid list of actions that you
could implement now across the country
and make things better
when 50 good cops resign from an entire
riot unit
that's not criminal justice reform
getting rid of bad cops
that's criminal justice reform but
that's not happening in places like
portland
and no one's spending their life behind
bars for smoking hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else